little box psalmody salt little boxes
made of ticky tacky little boxes only
this time and they all look just the
same you want to control your life but
life isn't a science experiment you
can't contain your world forever try
doing one thing that scares you over
break okay yeah this serves as an entry
voucher for meiosis escape rooms the
first super most immersive room yet and
win a million dollars so uh when does
the game start
I think this is the escape room you
should look for clues what are we
looking for here anything that looks
like a puzzle or code it looks like an
oven dial
well that's creepy as hell for 15 months
talk about a person what's wrong with
you that was real Wow
dumb question are we outside sooner get
this figured out soon we get the hell
out of here
watching us to know everyone's over leak
everything about us this is my hospital
bed me too
they made these rooms for us I never
seen things that weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
yes
you
you